und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
und marietta slomka
guten abend in new york ist der un
sicherheitsrat zusammengetreten um über
die lage am ukrainischen atomkraftwerk
buschehr zu sprechen dass das dort
hochgefährlich ist steht außer frage
aber das ist ja auch das kalkül der
russen was sein akw ein ort ist an dem
man sich verschanzen und munition lagern
kann ohne massiven raketenbeschuss
befürchten zu müssen nicht so wie es
ihnen möglicherweise auf der krim
widerfahren ist dass die explosionen auf
dem militärstützpunkt durch einen unfall
ausgelöst wurden glaubt jedenfalls kaum
ein militärexperte dazu gleich noch ein
gespräch die ukraine selbst senden der
wahl social media dazu deutliche
botschaften an die russische seite
lara banik berichtet
ihr hattet einige optionen für diesen
sommer mit diesem provokanten video
empfiehlt das ukrainische
verteidigungsministerium urlaub im
ausland nicht jedoch auf der krim der
adressat russische staatsbürger du
wolltest die krim großer fehler bilder
der explosionen auf dem russischen
luftwaffenstützpunkt sacchi menschen
fliehen zeit nach hause zu gehen
musikalisch untermalt mit dem song cruel
summer die krim gehört zur ukraine so
die eindeutige botschaft
dieser russische krieg gegen die ukraine
und gegen das ganze freie europa begann
mit der krim und muss mit argumenten mit
ihrer befreiung
russland behauptet durch ein feuer auf
einem lagergelände seien lediglich
mehrere explosionen von munition
ausgelöst worden sozusagen ein unfall
selensky spricht von großen schäden und
erfolgen
in nur einem tag haben die besatzung
kampfflugzeuge verloren 9 auf der krim
und eines bei sabrina die besatzer
erleiden erhebliche verluste bei
kampffahrzeugen munition und bei ihren
versorgungsrouten
ein kampf um die deutungshoheit vorher
nachher bilder zeigen dass mindestens
sieben kampfflugzeuge komplett zerstört
und weitere beschädigt wurden russlands
propaganda nach der grundsätzlich alles
nach russischen plan läuft bemüht sich
verstärkt den fokus zu verlagern so
inszeniert das russische
verteidigungsministerium
neben zahlreichen videos die die
streitkräfte bei der vermeintlichen
militärischen spezialoperation zeigen
auch die wachsende sorge um die
sicherheit des akw es in sabrina
in den letzten tagen haben ukrainische
einheiten das gelände von sapori
schossen das ist ein akt des
atomterrorismus und könnte eine
katastrophe auslösen die das ausmaß des
nuklearunfalls von tschernobyl deutlich
übertreffen wird
der ukrainische präsident warnt
ebenfalls russland könne in sapporo
einen super-gau auslösen aus der gegend
um das akw wird seit tagen heftiger
beschuss gemeldet doch wie
wahrscheinlich ist eine nukleare
katastrophe sollte das akw im kampf
schaden nehmen das müsste dann schon ein
sehr schwerer und gezielter angriffs
seien die kraftwerke sind ja so wie
andere reaktoren gleicher bauart oder
auch gleichen alters üblich mit einem
sogenannten stahlbeton containment das
ist sozialistischer behälter ausgerüstet
selbst wenn dieses container durch
beschuss beschädigt würde bedeutet das
nicht automatisch dass es zu einem
kerntechnischen ereignis kommen noch ist
das atomkraftwerk intakt die schweren
kämpfe in der ukraine gehen auch an tag
1 167 weiter anders ist bislang galt die
krim als praktisch unangreifbar die
jüngsten ereignisse könnten das
kriegsgeschehen in eine neue richtung
gelenkt haben
rostock russell ist uns zugeschaltet
militärexperte insbesondere auch für
russland mit dem forschungsschwerpunkt
militärstrategie am european council on
foreign relations und ehemaliger
österreichischer offizier genannte
adresse
also die sache auf der krim dass da
irgend ein russischer soldat
versehentlich neben dem munitionsdepot
geraucht hat und deshalb das ganze dinge
die luft geflogen hat die wird ja
eigentlich von allen experten auch von
ihnen für wenig plausibel gehalten was
ist denn ihr wahrscheinlichste szenario
was genau da geschehen ist das problem
ist man kann hier nur mit
wahrscheinlichkeiten arbeiten und man
kann varianten ausschließen die ihr
unwahrscheinlich sind dazu gehört
natürlich der raucher unfall und man
kann vermuten was wahrscheinlicher ist
also auch unwahrscheinlich würde ich den
sabotageakt ansehen einfach weil es
schwierig ist am hellichten tage eine
basis unbemerkt ein zukommen wenn auch
keine anzeichen dass die russen nach
irgendwelchen sabotage teams dann im
anschluss gesucht haben also bleibt im
grunde der drohnenangriff oder der
raketenangriff über bei beiden muss man
sagen die bilder sind von alle bilder
die wir von dem ereignis haben sind von
sehr weit weg aufgenommen das heißt es
ist wirklich schwer zu sagen man kann
kaum rückschlüsse ziehen ich halte den
raketenangriff für den
wahrscheinlichsten einfach aufgrund der
art der einschläge der tiefe krater
ich habe dann ja ein relativ weit
reichende raketen
ukrainische stellungen sind ja dann
süden so um die 200 kilometer entfernt
ja also es kann sich dabei nicht um die
gewöhnlichen artillerie raketen handeln
mit denen wir es bis jetzt in diesem
krieg zu tun haben wie es kann auch es
sich um nichts handeln was etwa von
seiten der usa oder andere nato-staaten
an die ukraine geliefert worden ist es
gibt ein paar systeme die in der ukraine
in entwicklung waren und es könnten
zumindest prototyp raketen natürlich
gewesen sein die das verursacht haben
das ist etwa wenn wir unsere neptun
erinnern die die moskwa versenkt hat
diese rakete da hat er auch niemand
gewusst wie viele und gibt es die jetzt
überhaupt einsatzfähig oder nicht und
dann kommt dieser einst so ähnlich
könnte das auch mit der chrome gewesen
sein auf jeden fall an eine unangenehme
überraschung für die russische seite hat
das weitreichende bedeutung für das
kriegsgeschehen
das werden wir auch sehen ob es jetzt
weitere schläge in die tiefe geht auf
jeden fall macht es die russen nervös
das problem dass diese raketen wenn es
sie wie gesagt in größerer anzahl gibt
eine weit höhere reichweite haben als
die bisherigen durch die ukraine
eingesetzt und das heißt eine ganze
reihe von luftwaffenstützpunkten von
nachschub lagern von eisenbahn
knotenpunkten kämen dann in die
reichweite dieser raketen und man muss
sich russischer seite gedanken machen
diese zu schützen durch flieger
abwehrsysteme beziehungsweise die
logistik weiter zu dezentralisieren
große lager aufzulösen auf viele kleine
zu verteilen um sich weniger verwundbar
machen dann ist man zwar weniger
verwundbar aber dann geht natürlich der
nachschub langsame und das ist dann auch
ein problem man fragt sich ja auch wenn
sowohl die russische flugabwehr gewesen
ist gibt es die nicht oder sind das doch
nur attrappen also die russen benutzen
ja auch attrappen so aufblasbarer
plastikball
flugabwehrsysteme die den gegner
täuschen sollen aber die werden auch ein
paar echte haben die haben durch sein
war echt das ist natürlich auch die
überraschende sache denn es sind im
umfeld dieser luftwaffenbasis da gibt es
zwei s400 bataillone die es für 100 ist
ein system dass dieses dass solche
raketen eigentlich abschließen könnte
auch sehen könnte von ihren radaranlagen
aber ich glaube das vorhandensein von
aufblasbaren
ist schon ein bisschen ein hinweis das
schiefgegangen ist das heißt nämlich
dass die russen auch angst hatten dass
die ukraine auf der krim rhade anlagen
und fliege systeme angreifen deshalb
stellen sie attrappen auf ein weiteres
mittel sich gegen angriffe zu schützen
weil er raketen die etwa die usa
geliefert haben die speziell auf liga
wer raketen abzielen geht das radler
anteilen also die die elektromagnetische
emissionen deshalb schaltet man
radaranlagen dann ausgeschaltet sie nur
auf standby und hat wenige radaranlagen
nur im betrieb um möglichst wenig ziele
dem gegner zu bieten das hat aber das
problem wenn jetzt nur ein radio aktiv
ist anstatt vier oder fünf dann hängt es
von diesem einen radler bediener ab ob
er jetzt den raketenangriff entdeckt
oder nicht und der am ende der schicht
ist nicht aufmerksamkeit ist diese diese
raketenangriff für die passieren in
bruchteilen von von minuten in der hat
im grunde wenige sekunden auf das ding
zu reagieren und wenn er das verschlaft
und wenn es nur ein raser ist dann ist
das der schaden sofort angerichtet und
jetzt noch mal kurz zum schluss so quasi
aus der vogelperspektive drauf gucken
die ukrainische armee die versuchten die
initiative zu kommen also quasi den
russen auch etwas aufzuzwingen was wo
wann geschieht aber
ist das ist die armee inzwischen so gut
ausgerüstet auch vom westen dass sie da
wirklich in die offensive kommen kann
in größeren teilen würde ich sagen fehlt
es ihr noch an schwerem gerät wird noch
ein gepanzerter mobilität gerade im
süden das gelände ist flach da komme ich
ohne schützenpanzer im grunde nicht
weiter
die ukrainische armee wird natürlich
auch von tag zu tag stärker die reserve
einheiten die die immobilie machten
einheiten die werden weiter trainiert
etwa jetzt in großbritannien die halten
mehr gerät von tag zu tag das heißt man
wird stärker auf der russischen seite
nutzt sich der apparat ab aber wir sind
jetzt in einer situation wo man sich in
etwa die waage hält die russen kommen
nicht mehr wirklich gut voran aber die
den ukrainern fehlt auch noch die
feuerkraft um wirklich große offensiven
zu leisten um kers und wenn sie es
schaffen die brücken zu unterbrechen
dann können sie vielleicht
abgeschnittene russische verbände
schlagen aber größere offensive würde
ich eher sagen kommen bisschen später
vielleicht im herbst die einschätzung
von militärexperten gustav preislich
danken für das gespräch vielen
herzlichen dank
nach konkreten waffenlieferungen wie
stets den aktuellen leoparden geparden
wohl kanzler scholz heute nicht so
intensiv befragt wie noch vor ein paar
wochen bei seiner sommerpressekonferenz
in berlin ging es mehr um das große
ganze des krieges und seiner folgen und
vor allem um finanzielles olaf scholz
setzt mit dem termin jedenfalls eine
tradition fort die angela merkel
eingeführt hatte kurz vor oder nach
ihrem sommerurlaub stellte sie sich
nochmal ausführlich den fragen der
hauptstadt journalisten und so macht es
jetzt auch ihr nachfolger lasst uns sagt
man dabei
der kanzler ohne krawatte mit offenem
hemd der termin vor der hauptstadtpresse
ist immer auch einer zur eigenwerbung da
gilt es nicht zugeknöpft zu wirken
ukraine krieg gaskonflikt grassierende
inflation
olaf scholz ist der kanzler der krise
und präsentiert seine version von hier
schaffen das wir werden alles dafür tun
dass die bürgern und bürger durch diese
schwierige zeit kommt mir geht es dabei
um diejenigen die ganz wenig haben und
deshalb haben wir gesagt wir wollen beim
wohngeld was machen wann bürgergeld und
sind dabei intensiv diese in form
vorzubereiten unruhen im herbst fürchte
er nicht so scholz sein mantra heute wie
seit wochen wir kümmern uns wir machen
und da wo noch was fehlt legen wir nach
unter anderem mit einem dritten
hilfspaket es wird auch ein weiteres
paket geben dass wir als bundesregierung
schnüren und mit dem wir den bürgern und
bürgern helfen werden dass sie die
herausforderung die mit gestiegenen
preisen verbunden sind auch bewältigen
können grundlegende differenzen in der
koalition spielt scholz herunter
gegenseitige kritik von grünen fdp und
der eigenen partei will er nicht
bewerten auffallend der
sozialdemokratische kanzler schlägt sich
häufig auf die seite von finanzminister
lindner keine über gewinn steuer keine
erhöhung des spitzensteuersatzes selbst
die schuldenbremse gilt ich habe sehr
unterstützt dass wir ein
haushaltsentwurf als bundesregierung
vorliegen der für 2003 und 20 sich an
die regeln des grundgesetzes hält
sowieso aber eben auch nicht von den
ausnahme möglichkeiten gebrauch gemacht
klare worte findet schon zum urheber der
meisten der derzeitigen probleme dem
russischen präsidenten putin aber als
kriegsverbrecher einzustufen vermeidet
er dann doch russische präsident trägt
die verantwortung für diesen krieg er
hat entschieden dass es ihm geben sollte
und das ist ein furchtbarer
unakzeptabler krieg an kriegt er gegen
alle regeln verstößt und der mit den
regeln bricht die wir miteinander
vereinbart haben etwas zugeknöpfter ist
scholz dann beim thema comex dem
untersuchungsausschuss der heute in
hamburg tagt nächste woche scholz
vernimmt sehe er trotz neuer
beschuldigungen gelassen entgegen
zweieinhalb jahre unglaublich viele
anhörungen unglaublich viele akten haben
nur ein ergebnis gebracht es gibt keine
erkenntnisse darüber dass es eine
politische beeinflussung gegeben hat die
umfragezahlen der spd sinken die
konflikte innerhalb der
regierungsparteien wachsen doch stolz
präsentiert sich als ein bundeskanzler
der sich in der dreier koalition keine
übertriebene parteilichkeit leisten will
es ist ja nicht so dass mit dem
koalitionsvertrag da einen
vereinigungsparteitag stattgefunden hat
sondern es sind drei unterschiedliche
parteien die auch mit unterschiedlichen
politischen programm angetreten so einer
vor allem scheint nach 106 minuten
fragen stellen sehr zufrieden zu sein
und das ist olaf scholz selbst die
eigentliche bewährungsprobe für ihn und
seine regierung dürfte allerdings noch
bevorstehen
und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von
hans bosch
us-justizminister gar land hat sich am
abend zu der durchsuchungsaktion im
anwesen von ex-präsident trump in
florida geäußert gallen und sagte er
habe den durchsuchungsantrag persönlich
genehmigt und habe nun ein gericht
gebeten diesen öffentlich zu machen
wegen des öffentlichen interesses in der
angelegenheit
nach medienberichten nach
medienberichten ging es bei der razzia
anfang der woche um regierungsdokumente
die trump in sein privates anwesend
mitgenommen haben soll
das robert koch institut hat seinen
neuen wochenbericht zur krone situation
veröffentlicht und darin heißt es dass
der aktuelle wellen gipfel überschritten
zu sein scheine trotzdem bleibe der
infektionsdruck in allen altersgruppen
groß in den kommenden wochen sei mit
einer weiterhin hohen zahl an
hospitalisierungen intensivmedizinischen
betreuung und todesfällen insbesondere
in höheren altersgruppen zu rechnen
rund ein viertel der klinikärzte innen
und ärzte denkt darüber nach ihren beruf
aufzugeben das ergab eine umfrage des
marburger bundes unter rund 8500
mitgliedern gründe dafür seien unter
anderem personalmangel überstunden und
zeitdruck jeder fünfte arzt oder ärztin
arbeiten demnach mehr als 60
wochenstunden durchschnittlich drei
stunden pro tag wenden sie für
dokumentation und verwaltung auf
das seit wochen oft heiße und trockene
wetter lässt die wasserstände in den
flüssen sinken wichtige wasser
transportwege wie die auf dem rhein sind
davon beeinträchtigt gerade jetzt da gas
knapp ist und kohle für die kraftwerke
gebraucht wird können die schiffe solche
abschnitte nur noch mit einer teil
beladung befahren
frankreich erhält im kampf gegen die
waldbrände der atlantikküste europäische
unterstützung vier feuerwehr flugzeuge
entsandte die eu-kommission über den
katastrophenschutz mechanismus außerdem
seien feuerwehrteams unter anderem aus
polen und deutschland auf dem weg sie
sollen etwa bei erneuten bränden südlich
von bordeaux die löscharbeiten
unterstützen jetzt seid kämpfen rund
1100 einsatzkräfte gegen die flammen
10.000 menschen mussten ihre wohnungen
verlassen
6800 hektar wurden von den flammen
bereits zerstört wir bleiben bei den
folgen von hitze und trockenheit in den
alpen schmelzen die gletscher so schnell
wie nie zuvor einer der insgesamt fünf
gletscher in deutschland könnte dieses
jahr verloren gehen grund vor allem der
rötliche saharastaub der hat sich
besonders im märz auf den gletschern
abgesetzt absorbiert mehr licht und
lässt so den schnee deutlich schneller
schmelzen nach einer neuen studie
vollziehen sich auch die veränderungen
in der arktis schneller die temperatur
stieg dort demnach in den letzten
jahrzehnten viermal schneller als im
globalen durchschnitt
das ist in deutschland einen massiven
investitionsstau gibt hat man nicht erst
in der pandemie gemerkt es dort
plötzlich reihum auf viel wie es um die
digitalisierung an deutschen schulen
steht aber es gibt ja zahlreiche
bereiche wo in den letzten jahrzehnten
von bundes- wie landesregierungen nicht
genug in die substanz investiert wurde
schienen straßen tausende brücken da
wird aus dem investitionsstau dann auch
ein mobilitäts stau ein besonders
krasses beispiel ist die talbrücke auf
der a 45 bei lüdenscheid da geht es um
das schicksal einer ganzen stadt und die
stimmung in einer ganzen region
berichtet
das autohaus maier in lüdenscheid
strategisch günstig liegt es schon mehr
als 20 jahre direkt an der a 45 über die
autobahn schnell zu erreichen ohne sich
durch die stadt zu quälen hier arbeitet
marie-christin knot als verkäuferin das
geschäft lief gut bis zum dezember 2021
dann musste die dame die talbrücke der
a45 voll gesperrt werden seitdem ist
alles anders nur noch stau wir haben
definitiv weniger kunden die ihre autos
in die werkstatt bringen oder uns fehlt
auch die laufkundschaft die sonst
nachmittags oder auch am wochenende
gerne gekommen sondern einfach mal sich
die fahrzeuge anzugucken probefahrten
muss man immer gucken wie man es
terminiert ist man möglichst wenig in
dieser rushhour stauzeit die kunden hier
hat weil wenn der kohle dafür nur
stunden im stau steht dann hat uns die
ganze profit auch nichts gebracht und
die momentan einzig mögliche umleitung
führt mitten durchs zentrum rund 43.000
lkw franken geschätzt pro woche durch
lüdenscheid heute war
bundesverkehrsminister volker wissing da
wo sich die brücken ruine anzusehen dem
lüdenscheider bürgermeister laufen die
arbeitskräfte davon wir merken das halt
das dass wir immer wieder menschen haben
die einfach sich wettbewerben die
kündigen versetzungsantrag stellen
und das ist natürlich ein standort
nachteil und deswegen das nachher auch
noch mal deutlich formulieren dass wir
hier in dieser region jetzt einfach auch
hilfe und unterstützung brauchen der
besuch wissens wurde mehrfach verschoben
den vorwurf er nehme das problem nicht
ernst genug weist der minister aber
zurück wir sind hier mit maximaler
beschleunigung unterwegs und diese
steuerungsgruppe wird auch von berlin
aus geleitet von meiner staatssekretärin
und die tag den sehr kurzen abschnitten
ich werde kontinuierlich unterrichtet am
nachmittag hat volker wissing zum
bürgergespräch geladen auch hier ist der
unmut groß
wenn ich jetzt mal eben kurz irgendwohin
möchte die kinder wollen vielleicht mein
sportverein das geht gar nicht mehr ich
kann nicht vier stunden meiner
lebenszeit am tag für diese scheiße
umleitung aufbauen wenn wir jetzt
irgendwelche termine haben dann überlegt
man mittlerweile ganz gezielt was könnte
man auf dieser strecke noch erledigen
weil morgen oder übermorgen möchte ich
das nicht noch mal fahren mindestens bis
2026 wird es dauern bis die a45 hier
wieder befahrbar ist zu viele
vorschriften finden viele
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt die fledermäuse
umweltbelange müssen aber beim neubau
berücksichtigt werden sagt der minister
trotzdem soll es schnell gehen
hier darf wieder fachkräftemangel noch
finanzielle themen zu einer verzögerung
führen und das ist sichergestellt durch
anweisungen die ich bereits im
vergangenen jahr getroffen habe noch vor
weihnachten soll die rahmen der
talbrücke die aprendo in rehmsdorf
fallen die neu bauarbeiten beginnen aber
frühestens im nächsten sommer
jetzt noch mal eins mit wirtschaft
energie unternehmen können höhere kosten
beim gaseinkauf ab oktober per umlage an
alle gaskunden weitergeben rwe kündigte
jetzt an diese möglichkeit nicht zu
nutzen frank wittmann will kommt naja
die essener beziehen weniger gas als
andere aus russland in einer
notsituation befindet sich der
stromproduzent schon gar nicht im
gegenteil wie blickt mit einem gewinn
von 2,8 milliarden euro vor zinsen und
steuern auf das beste halbjahr seiner
unternehmensgeschichte zurück der
konzern profitiert von der energiekrise
und den gestiegenen preisen rwe
verdienen vor allem mit seinen
erneuerbaren energien mit dem betreiben
von wind- und solarparks die unerwartet
hohen gewinne fallen rwe quasi in den
schoß der konzern kann mit seinen solar
und windkraftanlagen günstiger strom
erzeugen als gaskraftwerke darf seinen
günstig erzeugten strom aber abrechnen
zu den dramatisch gestiegenen kosten
eben dieser gaskraftwerke klingt
irgendwie paradox erklärt aber die
sprudelnden gewinne was so gut läuft
baut man aus das unternehmen kündigte
heute an in diesem jahr fünf milliarden
euro in den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien zu stecken investiert werde in
weitere windkraft und solaranlagen und
in den aufbau der wasserstoffwirtschaft
mit dem vorhaben die gewinne in die
energiewende zu stecken legt lenkt der
stromproduzent auch ab von einer
unangenehmen debatte nämlich den
profiteuren der energiekrise teile der
gewinne wegzunehmen in einigen ländern
hat man eine entsprechende steuer auf
rekord erträge bereits eingeführt
deutschland zögert noch frank widmen
vielen dank gerne
wieder ein unfall in einem freizeitpark
im legoland günzburg wurden mehr als 30
menschen verletzt einer davon schwer ein
achterbahn zug habe stark abgebremst der
folgen der seien auf gefahren erklärte
ein polizeisprecher wie es dazu kommen
konnte ist noch unklar
erst am wochenende war im
rheinland-pfälzischen klotten eine frau
als eine achterbahn gestürzt und
gestorben
mecklenburg-vorpommerns
ministerpräsident in schwesig hat die 31
hanse sail eröffnet es ist eines der
weltweit grössten windjammer und
traditionssegler treffen und findet in
diesem jahr wieder in vollem umfang
statt bis sonntag dauert das maritime
volksfest es werden hunderttausende
besucher am stadthafen der hansestadt
rostock sowie in warnemünde erwartet
zonenrandgebiet ist einer dieser fast
schon vergessenen begriffe aus den
zeiten der deutschen teilung der zonen
rand von dem man in westdeutschland
sprach bezog sich auf die sowjetische
besatzungszone aus der dann die ddr
wurde dieses foto hier wurde 1988 bei
lauenburg aufgenommen an der grenze
zwischen schließlich holstein und
mecklenburg vorpommern
längst durch deutschland von der ostsee
bis runter zur donau an die grenze zur
damaligen tschechoslowakei befanden sich
vormals zentrale region plötzlich am
rand dort wo alle wege endeten sie
gehörten zwar zu westdeutschland aber
das leben dort war ein anderes das
beschreibt die historikerin astrid
eckert eingehend in ihrem buch zum
randgebiet christa knöpfle berichtet
die brücke von demis sie führte einmal
über die elbe bei kriegsende zerstört
ist sie bis heute ein symbol der teilung
hier im niedersächsischen landkreis
lüchow dannenberg war das stille ende
der bundesrepublik der osten des westens
genannt zonenrandgebiet
das zonenrandgebiet war ein 40 kilometer
tiefer streifen von der ostsee bis
runter zum bayerischen wald also
wirklich ein recht großer teil des
westdeutschen territoriums nämlich fast
20 prozent und dieser streifen erhielt
seit mitte der fünfziger jahre
unterstützung vom bund der hat die
plötzliche grenzlage die
wirtschaftlichen nachteile der
plötzlichen grenzlage ausgleichen helfen
sollte doch trotz millionenschwerer
förderung blieb der westlichen rand das
armenhaus der bundesrepublik das
grenzgebiet zur ddr die dunkelste stelle
im wendland war hier im blut lingen
erinnert sich axel kahrs schauplatz
eines dramatisch gescheiterten
fluchtversuch das ist dieser hans frank
der
getötet worden ist
1973 weist 23 jahre alt der arzt der in
operierte bis zum tod ist mein arzt
gewesen das ging mir sehr nahe für die
historikerin eckert ist der zonen rand
ein füllhorn spannender geschichten die
berühmteste ist die von gorleben in
strukturschwache randlage sollte mit
milliardeninvestitionen atommüll
entsorgt werden hier am ende der welt
schlägt die geburtsstunde der grünen
gründen kam dann aus dem landkreis
lüchow-dannenberg die am längsten
anhaltende anti atom kampagne der
bundesrepublik also aus dieser
peripherie herauskam kam eine bewegung
die wirklich das zentrum mit beeinflusst
hat also die bundes- und die energie
geschichte der bundesrepublik mit
geprägt hat
die werra mainz ohne land fluss
transportiert seit jahrzehnten ihre
giftige fracht von thüringen nach hessen
der kali abbau auf beiden seiten machte
die vera zum salzig ssten fluss europas
ost und west handeln verbissen wer zahlt
die zeche
die westdeutschen haben versucht das
verursacherprinzip
anzuwenden die ddr verursacht den
schaden also muss er ihnen auch
aufräumen während die ddr argumentiert
hat ihr seid die nutznießer wenn wir
etwas unternehmen deshalb müsst ihr
dafür zahlen was wir hier an
schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen am ende
passierte nichts die werra ist bis heute
so salzig wie die ostsee weithin
sichtbar die neuen monte kali es
gigantische abraumhalden aus dem kali
abbau
tatsächlich sind es ewigkeitslasten sie
sollen nicht entfernt werden uns im
gegenteil sie sollen sich noch einmal
verdoppeln wirst du betriebseinstellung
bis 2060 werden die kali berger in den
himmel wachsen neuer monumente in der
mitte deutschlands im einstigen zum im
randgebiet
und von ehemaligen deutschen
randgebieten wechseln wir in einer herz
region nordamerikas die rocky mountains
ein sehnsuchtsort nicht nur für
amerikaner und kanadier
und auch ein wichtiger teil des
gründungsmythos der usa diese
gebirgsketten galt es zu bezwingen auf
dem weg richtung westen für die
sendereihe gebirgs welten sind unsere us
korrespondentin claudia bates und ihr
team durch die rockies gereist und die
reportage sehen sie jetzt gleich im
anschluss
wir melden uns dann morgen gern
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend so heiß wie es diesen sommer
ist so sehr sehnen wir uns nach kühlen
badeseen in stehenden gewässern aber
lauern gefahren die sonne erhitzt die
wasseroberfläche bei 25 grad
wassertemperatur vermehren sich algen
stark auch die als blaualgen bekannten
cyanobakterien sie sind giftig für
menschen besonders beim verschlucken und
noch mehr für fische zersetzen sich die
blaualgen verschwindet der sauerstoff
und das ist für fische lebensbedrohlich
was jetzt helfen würde wäre sinkende
temperaturen und regen beides ist
zurzeit nicht in sicht heute nacht ist
es klar und die temperaturen sinken auf
werte zwischen 18 und 10 grad und morgen
kommt ein weiterer sehr sonniger tag mit
nur wenigen wolken einzig in
südostbayern kann es am nachmittag mal
für ein gewitter reichen die
temperaturen erreichen morgen am
alpenrand 23 grad und bis auf 34 grad
steigt das quecksilber am niederrhein
das wochenende bringt wieder heißes
wetter temperaturen zwischen 25 und 35
grad und einzelne gewitter beschränkten
sich auf den äußersten osten aber in der
neuen woche dreht der wind auf südwest
und damit wird es schwül warm und
gewittrig bei temperaturen von 24 bis 33
grad am montag schönen abend noch